President Trump made his case yesterday
in a prime-time address he stuck to the
script read from a prompter explained
why we need a border wall or a barrier
guess I guess we're calling it a barrier
now and he explained why this shutdown
is really something that falls at the
feet of Democrats who could end it at
any time just by agreeing to allocate a
little bit of money a little bit of
money comparatively speaking to protect
the border and then we heard from Chuck
and Nancy in a Democrat rebuttal now you
see the Democrats knew that this was a
high-stakes thing very important
primetime responding to the president
and they needed to put their two best
people on the case and so it was Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi who stood
before the nation looking a lot like a
disgruntled old married couple who came
to the restaurant for brunch and are
very dissatisfied with the service and
are gonna go back to the retirement home
and tell all their friends about it and
everyone will sort of commiserate with
each other and agree that the service at
that place has really gone downhill over
the last 25 years and in their speech as
far as the actual content of it they
they explained how you know it's it's
not their fault it's actually Trump's
fault and so on now a few points here
about all of this number one I don't
think it it moved the needle at all I
don't think anyone was convinced I think
everyone whatever you thought about the
border wall and all of that and
immigration before last night you
probably think the same thing now I'm
not sure that anyone can be convinced of
anything anymore I think we're all just
sort of set and stuck in whatever we
think and it's not going to change
however I do think it was good to see in
any case it's still I think it's a good
there are a lot of people that have been
complaining about it for this or that
reason I've seen people argue that it
was a degradation of the presidency to
have the President and up there doing
this how is it a degradation you you've
got this is an important issue and so
the president is making his case in
front of the nation and on the other
side there may
in their case for whatever it's worth
that's what we should see it's a good
thing that's that's what we should see
more of that in America and you know
whatever programming it was interrupting
I think that this conversation is more
important than that programming unless
it was interrupting playoff football and
then I would say that's different but it
wasn't so whatever else it was was gonna
be on TV
this is more important I think it's it's
a even if it's not going to convince
anyone I just think it's a good thing in
principle and we should see we should
see more of this like bring you know
rather than funneling it through the
media or rather than the president
making his case on Twitter just bring it
in front of the American people like he
did so I thought that was good um also I
you know I'm I like scripted Trump I
like Trump when he's from operating from
a script he's on message he's focused
those are always his best moments is
when he is sticking to it when he's
reading a speech and sticking to a
script and when you see things like last
night it makes you think what could have
been maybe what could be with his
presidency if he got off a Twitter and
he stopped with the with the you know
pep rally stuff where he's going off
script and talking about you know
whatever CNN personality he dislikes
instead just sticking to what actually
matters and making the case that's the
good stuff now he might not be the most
gifted teleprompter reader in the world
but but there have been plenty of other
presidents who weren't very gifted in
that regard and it is a difficult thing
to do to stay in and look at a camera
and read from a script it seems easy but
it's actually not that easy and that
doesn't matter anyway the point is the
message now I know you could say well he
doesn't write the speeches so what I'm
really saying is my favorite Trump is
when he's saying things that aren't his
own words and I in a way I am saying
that but but of course no president
writes their own speeches but that's not
what
you know that's there's more to it than
that because the point is yeah although
Trump didn't write that speech he is
still willing to say things in a
scripted speech that other Republicans
are not willing to say and other
Republican presidents would never say
and never have said and he did it again
that the entire speech that he gave last
night he didn't write it fine but that's
it was a good speech and that was a
speech that other Republican presidents
wouldn't be willing to give and so
there's a lot of value in that if we can
get trumped doing the things that other
president the good things that other
presidents won't do yeah other
presidents also wouldn't spend all day
on Twitter getting into Twitter feuds
with you know Kathy Griffin or whoever
but but that's that's the stuff that
other presidents wouldn't do for good
reason but here now we have the we have
we have good things substantive things
that Trump is willing to do and so
that's why I like it good example I
thought his best line in the speech is
the one that a lot of people are
pointing out it's a good line he says
some have suggested a barrier is immoral
then why do wealthy politicians build
walls fences and gates around their
homes they don't build walls because
they hate the people on the outside but
because they love the people on the
inside the only thing that's immoral is
the politicians too who do nothing and
continue to allow more innocent people
to be horribly victimized that's a great
line now it's it's obviously not the
first time I've heard that line this is
a point that conservatives have been
making for years but it's good to hear
it from the Oval Office
from the president it's a good line to
have out there and it is unanswerable it
is an unanswerable point it completely
dismantles the arguments against the
wall or the barrier or whatever we're
calling it because as he said you you
can't say that there's something in
principle immoral about erecting you
know some sort of barrier to keep people
out when you
I on on that on that level of security
around your own home it just doesn't
make any sense or when you say build
bridges not walls okay well are you
building a bridge into your own home no
you build walls around your home and
your home itself consists of walls why
is that well it's the same sort of
principle so it that's why it's a good
line the only thing that Trump didn't do
in that speech that I wish he would have
done and I think would've been really
effective is if he had spent I spent
some time specifically quoting Nancy
Pelosi Chuck Schumer Obama other high
profile Democrats on this issue of the
wall and border security because all of
them in the past have come out in favor
of some kind of barrier on the southern
border they have all said that Hillary
Clinton is another one they've all said
things in the past about how obviously
we need to protect the border and now
they've changed their mind because Trump
is the one who wants it and he did
allude to that it's a good point but I
think he should have specifically quoted
them and if he had quoted Schumer and
Pelosi and then you immediately cut the
Schumer and Pelosi standing there about
to give their rebuttal
that would have been a very effective
moment but even aside from that it was
it was a good speech what we saw from
the Democrat rebuttal
is that they have no arguments here they
really have they have nothing to say
what's their argument against it too
expensive okay well yeah five billion
dollars there's a lot of money to you or
me but to the government it's nothing
these days unfortunately in comparison
to how much they spend on so many other
things on how much they spend on foreign
aid or on the welfare state or some of
the other things five billion dollars is
nothing in comparison so considering
Kratz support all of these other really
expensive measures they can't now
pretend that well you know what five
billion we just don't have it in the
budget we can't do it they can't become
fiscal heart hawks all the sudden on
this issue it doesn't make sense so they
what are they gonna say that's it's it's
immoral well we've already dealt with
that they obviously don't think walls
and security are immoral because they've
supported it in the past on the southern
border and they obviously in their own
lives rely on it so what it doesn't work
well we know that's not true you know
all you have to do is talk to Border
Patrol agents talk to the people who are
actually down there dealing with this
issue on a daily basis talk to the
people whose job is to deal with this
issue and they're going to say of course
some sort of physical barrier is going
to be extremely effective it's not gonna
solve the problem in and of itself but
it's going to be an effective measure
it's going to it's a big help to have it
and if you look at the portions of the
border where we have a physical barrier
right now you're gonna find that there's
a lot there's a lot less illegal
crossing of course because it's more
difficult to do that just makes sense so
they have no argument their only real
argument is is that Trump wants to do
this and we don't want to give him a win
so that's why we don't want it but they
can't say that so they have to resort to
other talking points that make no sense
so okay that said there's there's an
question here that I think conservatives
should be asking and most conservatives
are not asking and that is why did Trump
wait until right now to take this stand
Republicans controlled the House and the
Senate for two years leading up to this
they passed budgets several times Trump
could have said any time in 2017 or 2018
I'm not gonna sign a budget that doesn't
have border wall funding he could have
said that he could have taken that stand
then and he didn't if he had taken that
stand in 2017 we would have a wall right
now or at least the the beginnings of
the makings of a wall we'd have portions
of a wall built so it seems very odd to
me that he he waited to take this stand
and take us into a shutdown he waited
until Democrats controlled the house to
do it it just makes no sense and it's
it's part of a it's part of a pattern
with Republican this is what Republicans
always do they wait to try and do
something until they no longer have the
power to do it have you noticed that
Republicans become very forceful very
principled you know fighters the moment
they no longer have the power to
actually do all the things they're
saying they want to do and that really
troubles me it troubles me to that's
been the trend with Republicans for
decades now and we're seeing it we're
seeing it continue with with President
Trump and you can't tell me well you
know he couldn't do it before because
because Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
first of all okay so you're telling me
what Trump was was he couldn't do it
because they told him no all right well
now we've got Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi who are saying no but he's not
listening to them is he he's saying he's
saying I don't care what what you say
about it
this is important and it needs to be
done so he's willing to have that fight
with Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi
it wasn't willing to have that fight
with his people in his own party it just
doesn't make sense that's the big
question here is yeah I mean it's
literally as soon as Democrats took over
that's when Trump says all right let's
get that wall built it could have easily
been done before that no problem I mean
do you really think that that Paul Ryan
and Mitch McConnell would have let a
government shutdown go on for weeks
refusing to you know to allocate the
funds for a border wall no way they
could have easily been forced into it
it's gonna be really hard to force
Democrats into it because for Democrats
there's no incentive what's the there's
very little incentive for Democrats to
cave that they don't want the wall they
don't want to give Trump a win
their base doesn't want it so it's this
is a very difficult fight to win for
that reason because there's not much in
it for them to cave but if you want to
put this all on establishment
Republicans before they wouldn't let the
wall get built were there with there
would have been huge incentives for them
to give in if Trump had actually had you
know had that fight and took in that
stand taking that took him taking that
stand and said this is going to get done
there would have been huge incentives
for Republicans to go along because
their base wants it it's something they
said they they always wanted you know
they're all part of the same party so
the huge incentives now there's no
incent now he's dealing with people who
he has very little leverage over because
they want two completely different
things and their bases want two
completely different things he could
have done it for two years he waited
till now again he's it's not unique I
mean this is what Republicans do but
he's just it's the same pattern it
always repeats itself and what troubles
me about it is that it really seems like
Republicans are not as interested in
actually doing things in fact they don't
want to do anything they want an excuse
so they want that they want to pretend
they're trying to do something and then
have the Democrats prevent it and then
they can point fingers the Democrats say
oh we want to do it but we can't and
then they can go into the you know and
then they can go to the re-election
campaign said Oh reelect us so that we
could actually do it this time and then
it's just on and on and on it continues
like that but then they never actually
have to do the thing so that's an
important question I think that needs to
be asked of President Trump why did you
wait until now why now I hope it gets
done this important thing but we had two
years to do it it seems really strange
that now all of a sudden this isn't the
number one priority
all right um let's see the latest famous
liberal to be devoured by his own side
is Bryan Cranston
Bryan Cranston who is a the star of my
favorite television show of all time
breaking bread Breaking Bad and court
reading now from The Daily wire it says
former Breaking Bad star Bryan Cranston
is being forced to defend his decision
to play a severely disabled man in an
upcoming film called the upside after
social justice warriors criticized both
Cranston and the studio for not casting
a true quadriplegic in the role the BBC
reports the Cranston is speaking out
defending not just his business decision
to star alongside Kevin or to note
Nicole Kidman in the dramatic comedy
premiering this month but also defending
his right as an actor to take roles that
force him to leave his comfort zone and
adopt a new persona Cranston said we
live in the war in in the world of
criticism if we're willing to get up and
try something we have to also be willing
to take criticism we're very aware of
the need to expand the opportunities for
people with disabilities the Ruderman
Family Foundation which advocates on
behalf of disabled Americans was quick
to point out that Cranston took a role
that could have gone to an actor
actually suffering from
complete paralysis taking a page from
previous campaigns against white actors
playing people of color the foundation
suggested that Cranston's casting was
discrimination others primarily social
justice advocates compared Cranston's
portrayal of a quadriplegic man to black
face and on and on it goes now of course
this is absurd it's it's acting he's
playing a role that's the whole point of
acting he's pretending to be something
that he isn't that's the point okay
Daniel day-lewis portrayed he also
portrayed a severely disabled man in a
great in a great movie called my left
foot which I guess just would not fly
these days but he portrayed Abraham
Lincoln a few years ago he's not
actually Abraham Lincoln okay now we all
know that but he's pretending to be
Abraham Lincoln because that's what
acting is that's the point
and that actually a lot of times that's
how we identify really great acting
performances is when someone is playing
a character that is really that's far
outside of who they actually are so
that's why it's I haven't seen the movie
but if Cranston really pulls off this
performance we would say well that's a
great acting performance because he's
not himself quadriplegic so to try to
inhabit that role must be pretty
difficult right to play a historical
person that's the person has existed far
outside of your own environment your own
culture that's a difficult thing to do
so we say well that's a great that was a
great acting performance
I mean how look I don't how many
quadriplegic actors are there to choose
from in the first place
I'm not saying there
denne but it's just and in any case
that's not when you're looking to cast a
role what you're looking and I've never
been through this process myself I don't
work in Hollywood but it seems to me
what you're saying to yourself and
you're looking to cast a role is let's
find someone who is really good at
pretending to be this thing because
that's what acting is so obviously it's
ridiculous but you know as I said this
is just Bryan Cranston liberal Hollywood
celebrity like like many others now he's
being devoured by his own I just think
at what point Ari whatever reasonable
leftist might still exist out there
however many reasonable leftists are
left on that side I would just say to
them I would appeal to them and maybe
Bryan Cranston is among them I don't
know but you know now's the time to get
out I'm not saying you have to leave
leftism and immediately become a
conservative I'm just saying that now's
the time you know to separate yourself
from that because you
how crazy it is and you just with these
Hollywood celebrities especially
recently when they're getting in trouble
for things and they're facing backlash
and outrage it's always from their own
side
I mean conservatives could complain all
the time about about the stuff you see
in Hollywood and we do complain
sometimes rightfully so but most of the
big outrages the the the the the
backlash people losing their jobs
controversies all that these days most
of it is coming from the left and so
that is my appeal to any reasonable
leftists that remain is you can leave
you can disassociate yourself from all
of that because they you know there's
they're going to turn on you eventually
and devour you I think we've seen that
by now finally I received this email a
few days ago and I've been wanting to
respond to it it's kind of a standard
millennial lament but there's a point
that I wanted to make about it so here's
the email it says Matt can you talk
about the narcissism of the millennial
generation I've noticed that there are
they are very self-centered and can't
see beyond themselves and now we've got
millennial politicians like AOC
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez in office and I
fear that the path they will take us
down as a country is a very bad one and
it continues from there yes the
narcissistic selfish Millennials the
email or is right of course there are a
lot of people and in that category in my
generation no question and we're going
to talk about how they ended up that way
but it should be stated up front that
narcissism is not a problem unique to
young people I don't think there's any
evidence that it's even appreciably
worse among the young I don't think
there's any evidence of that or any
reason to believe it I mean if you look
at the baby boomer boomer generation
you're not going to see very much
evidence of selflessness and generosity
in that generation okay
and if you look at boomer politicians
now so you could say look if Alexandria
Kaiser Cortez is the millennial
representative of my generation in
Congress then we'll think about all the
representatives of the boomer generation
that have been on the political scene
over the last few decades among boomers
you see some of the worst political
leaders our country has ever endured
let's start with the Clintons okay and
go from there but this isn't a
generational squabble this is just the
human condition selfishness is part of
the human condition it's ingrained in us
and a lot of work has to be done
starting at a very young age to pride
people away from that self-centered way
of thinking and these days it's true
that that work is often not done or at
least it's not done very well and it's
also clear that it wasn't always done
well back in the old days either so
here's I think the problem it's very
it's it's very difficult to look at the
world and realize that you yourself are
not the star player you aren't even a
very significant player at all now but
you experience things through your own
prism because what other choice do you
have
and in experiencing things that way you
start to see everything as if it exists
in relation to you everything is defined
by its relation to you so you say and
all people are also defined by their
relationship to you so you say well
that's my brother that's my friend
that's my child that's my spouse that's
my mother that's my coworker that's a
stranger that's my neighbor that's a
random person and so on everyone is
labeled and categorized according to how
they fit into your life and again that's
unavoidable and there's nothing wrong
with it in principle there's no other
way for us to think about these things
but the trouble is that we can easily
revert back to this default way of
thinking where my brother and my friend
and
my child and my spouse and my co-worker
all of these people are solely and only
those things so they are mine in effect
in the end they are defined only by
their relationship to me and they have
no existence outside of that I am the
only fully formed fully independent
complex interesting emotional human
being in the world now of course very
few people will think this way in the
front of their minds explicitly most
people are going to go around saying
stuff like this but it's just kind of a
general unexamined attitude that we all
carry around with us and it will bleed
more and more into our conscious
thoughts unless we make the effort to
see the world differently and a lot of
that work does have to be done at a
young age so like with my kids my kids
are very young and they don't they
really don't understand yet or they
can't fully understand that the world
doesn't revolve around them I mean they
really think it does because my oldest
are twins are five years old so that's
just what they think and they look at
they look at my wife and I and and they
think well we're mom and dad and we are
but they can't conceive of the idea that
we might be more than that as well we
might be other things on top of that so
they see us and they think that our
whole point in life is to care for them
and be at their beck and call all the
time that's just what they think and
that's why kids always had they they
have no problem interrupting a
conversation that adults are having
because in their minds they think well I
have something I want to say to mommy
and of course mommy's gonna listen right
now and drop everything she's doing
because she's my mommy and she she can't
possibly have anything else she wants to
talk about or do right now except just
attend to me over time kids have to be
helped to overcome this way of thinking
and that's what growth is about but
often that work is not done and they
aren't taught to think unselfishly and
often they are taught exactly the
opposite especially these days whether
it's constantly put into their heads
that that you're special you're you know
you're wonderful and some of that in
moderation is okay but when that's
constantly the message and there's never
a humbling message on top of it then the
problem only gets worse and worse and
more harmful as they get older but it's
very hard you know it's very hard to
think unselfishly and to truly live in a
way that is not self-centered because
that involves more than like giving the
charity and being a nice person I mean
you could do those two things and still
be a very self-centered person I think
it involves seeing the world in a
completely different way and it involves
an immense amount of humility it
involves the realization that I myself
now I'm a child of God so that makes me
sacred and valuable but in terms of the
general scheme of what the world has
going on as far as everyone else is
concerned in terms of the day-to-day
practicality I'm really not that
important I could die tomorrow and a you
know most people wouldn't care I could
die tomorrow and a few people would be
completely devastated
a few more people not as close to
but still somewhat close would be really
sad for a while and in my specific case
I think some of you might be a little
sad and you would say oh well you know
that's that's really sad I can't believe
that he was so young and then some of
you might be quite pleased about the
news actually
but then the vast majority of people on
earth almost everyone in comparison
won't even notice
it'll mean absolutely nothing to them
the world would just continue along
without me and so many billions of
people won't even know what they're
missing they'll never know that I'm gone
because they never knew that I existed
in the first place you know that's
that's kind of the realization that we
always have to have in our minds if we
actually want to live and think
unselfishly and not turn into absolute
narcissists and we might say well that's
kind of a depressing thought but it's
not really depressing it's just a
recognition that the world in fact does
not revolve around me and that's okay
it's kind of exciting actually what a
boring world it would be if it actually
did revolve around me what a boring
world it would be if I actually was the
center of it I mean have you ever had
this thought I'm sure you have you know
we've what we've all thought this when
we're driving down the highway or
something and then you're driving along
and a car passes by you and you think to
yourself the person in that car is a
person they have their own dreams and
hopes and fears their own life their own
story it's a story that's happening out
there completely apart from me and I am
totally irrelevant to it and they're
gonna go on and live their life and we
cross our paths that will never cross
again and that's just a totally separate
existence from me I don't see that as
sad I see it as sort of beautiful and
it's absolutely necessary this
realization is absolutely necessary in
order to become a well developed an
adjusted person this by the way I think
is one of the reasons why really famous
celebrities often become drug addicts
and wackos because it's very hard to
develop and adjust in their situation
you know whereas most of us on a daily
basis
we have this very freeing and humbling
and refreshing experience of being in
large crowds of strangers or passing by
strangers on the sidewalk or on the
highway and being just one of those
strangers in relation to them being kind
of a nobody a nameless face a member of
the crowd we all have that experience
most of us anyway all the time when we
go out in public but if you're a famous
celebrity you've never had that
experience or at least it's been a very
long time since you've had it so if
you're you know Johnny Depp well Johnny
Depp is Johnny Depp wherever he goes he
is he is never a nameless face he's
never just a member of the crowd he is a
part of everyone's story because we all
know his name we've seen his films now
of course we know he's not a very
important part of our story if Johnny
Depp died tomorrow we would all say oh
that's too bad he was a real talent
you know things went off the rails it's
too bad maybe we would post something on
social media about it but then we go on
and we live our life and you know we go
to the store we need dinner and we
wouldn't even think about it that much
we wouldn't be that terribly broken up
about it not because we're sociopaths
but just because we're living our own
lives and Johnny Depp actually is not at
the centre of our lives but from Johnny
Depp's perspective everyone knows him
everyone makes a big deal about him
anytime he walks into a work room
everyone goes holy crap it's Johnny Depp
and so how can someone in that position
not become an egomaniacal lunatic to be
really down-to-earth as a famous
celebrity just takes a that is just a
Herculean feat of modesty and humility
and most people aren't capable of that
and so that's why so few of them really
are down to earth and most of them are
insane because I think Fame at that
level drives you insane
because there is just no humbling force
in your life at all but most of us don't
have that problem and I think that's a
good thing as I said
it's it's freeing as well there's a
there's a famous quote I don't know who
it originates with but it goes something
like this that you'll be a lot less
worried about what people think of you
when you realize how seldom they do you
know and I think that's if we want to
talk about what are we supposed to say
to kids to stop them from from being
narcissists I think that's one of the
most important things they can learn and
it's not depressing it is a freeing
thing so I think it's one of the you
know when kids are really worried about
you know someone said something mean to
them at school or this or that person
doesn't like them I think maybe you
think of a delicate way to put it but a
message that needs to be communicated to
them is that well number one you
shouldn't care what they think because
who you know you shouldn't live your
life that way but but also those people
don't really care that much I know they
said that mean thing to you but they
don't really care I mean they're you
know they're there where they're off
somewhere right now and not even
thinking about you they just don't care
that much it's not that important to
them oh you feel like you embarrassed
yourself at school today
you know nobody cares I mean they might
kind of laugh about it but they're not
thinking about it right now right now
you're the only one in the world
thinking about it know what everyone
else has moved on because they don't
care that much about you in the first
place as I said I think we I think we
maybe would be delicate about the way we
communicate that the kids especially
when they're younger but that is just
them and it's something we all as adults
we need to realize when we sit around
worrying about you know how did I come
across or what do people think of me
they're not really thinking about you
they don't really care that much because
you're not the center of their life you
are a very very very minor player in
their life and for most people you're
not a player at all and it is that is in
that realization that we can have
humility and and not be narcissist and
so you know my jitan the millennial
generation do they have a more difficult
time with this concept probably
and that we could get into the what you
know media on the Internet and how that
kind of feeds into this self-centered
way of thinking about that we can get
into that we won't get into it now but
yeah there's it's probably a bigger at
least a slightly bigger problem now than
it used to be and I think this is how we
get over it all right we'll leave it
there thanks for everybody thanks for
watching everybody Godspeed talk to you
tomorrow